revista de prensa en directo américa de
france 24 rosa pérez mateo conmigo en el
estudio rosa bienvenida buena mañana de
martes vamos a abrir entonces esta
revista de prensa con euros análisis de
resultados electorales que hace el medio
independiente colombiano llamado la
silla vacía rosa esto sobre la primera
vuelta presidencial del pasado domingo
29 de mayo el país se del no es la
nación rodolfista que quiere decir bueno
raúl buenos días pues este el país del
no hace referencia a los resultados del
plebiscito por los acuerdos de paz con
la extinta guerrilla de las farc de 2016
y es que en este análisis la silla
vacía' particularmente los periodistas
con esteban lewin y manuel a galvis lo
que hacen es una comparativa de la
distribución territorial de los votos de
esta primera vuelta presidencial como
decías del domingo 29 de mayo con otros
comicios que han tenido lugar en el país
en primer lugar vemos estos mapas que a
lo que hacen referencia es a la
comparación como decíamos de esta
primera vuelta presidencial del pasado
domingo
con la segunda vuelta presidencial de
2018 que enfrentó recordemos a la
presidente saliente iván duque con el
izquierdista gustavo petro que ha sido
en esta primera vuelta de este 2022 el
candidato recordemos más votado con más
del 40 por ciento de los apoyos y al
comparar esta segunda vuelta de 2018 con
la primera de 2022 lo que vemos es que
en 2018 el país estaba bastante pintado
de azul que son a los departamentos con
más o menos intensidad donde el
candidato más votado fue iván duque y
vemos que cuando trasladamos los
resultados a la primera vuelta de este
2022 la mayoría del territorio pintado
en azul en 2018 se pinta ahora de lila
que son los departamentos donde ganó el
independiente rodolfo hernández no el
ingeniero multimillonario que algunos
llaman el trump colombiano mientras que
los departamentos pintados de rosa pues
son ahí donde gustavo petro fue el
candidato más votado y vemos que pues se
mantienen incluso se amplían
territorios haciendo esta comparativa de
cuatro años vamos a ver lo que acaba
sucediendo el próximo 19 de junio en
este balotaje y comentamos también otro
gráfico que se ve en este mismo artículo
que en lo que hace la silla vacía es
los 20 municipios donde el rechazo
a los acuerdos de paz en 2016 fue más
agudo no donde se cosecharon más nos
digamos en proporción a la población y
lo que se ve en el gráfico de barras es
que en estos 20 municipios digamos a
donde el no obtuvo cerca del 80 por
ciento el candidato más votado fue de
lejos el independiente de rodolfo
hernández seguido de federico gutiérrez
el candidato oficioso digamos de la
derecha uribista que recordemos el
movimiento uribista también hizo una
activa campaña por el no en el
plebiscito por estos acuerdos de paz
decíamos con la extinta guerrilla de las
farc cambiamos ahora de tema rosa vamos
a ir con otro de los temas del día
repasamos las portadas del nacional post
y el globe and mail como titulan las
propuestas del primer ministro dio sin
trono sobre la nueva regulación
armamentística esto por supuesto tras la
masacre que vimos anual de texas
exactamente pues empezando por el
national post lo que reprochan un poco
al presidente es que reaccione pues a
temas de la agenda estadounidense no
porque claramente esta propuesta de ley
pues tiene que ver con el tiroteo masivo
en texas en eeuu y no tanto con los
problemas que tiene canadá no que
recordemos no tiene la misma situación
de descontrol de armas que su vecino
pues eeuu y precisamente el national
post dice importando las guerras
culturales estadounidenses raza armas y
aborto dice el primer ministro justin
trudeau ha cogido la costumbre de
adoptar posturas de política nacional
que parecen dirigidas a un público
estadounidense y precisamente dice pues
claro que lo que quiera decir yo es que
lo está tomando canadá y eeuu todavía no
termina de reaccionar digamos los
dirigentes en eeuu un problema tan grave
lo que ocurre en su país también le
tiran piedras a justine trudeau cuando
pues estaría haciendo también una
política para prevenir que se cometan
hechos como los que vemos en eeuu
exactamente no aparte de que él pues
sostiene que muchas de las armas que
llegan a su país vienen importadas de
forma ilegal desde eeuu y esta es una de
las cosas que se quiere evitar con esta
nueva legislación digamos que el
nacional pues pone otros ejemplos no
como decíamos que el primer ministro por
ejemplo justin trud o sea se arrodilló
en un acto digamos en un gesto anti
racista tras el asesinato de georges
floyd no pues en eeuu también por otro
lado también han dijo que todas las
mujeres tenían derecho al aborto legal y
seguro en canadá después de que se
filtrara pues esas débil deliberaciones
no de la corte suprema de eeuu según las
cuales los magistrados no de este órgano
superior de justicia quisieran revocar
la sentencia de roe versus wait que es
la que garantiza el derecho al aborto a
nivel federal y pues por último no esta
reacción a la masacre en esta escuela de
uralde en texas y por otro lado pues the
globe and mail
al contrario lo que le reprocha es que
la propuesta de ley no sea lo
suficientemente ambiciosa dice ottawa
quiere a frenar las ventas y las
importaciones de pistolas pero se queda
corto respecto a la prohibición total y
lo que vemos es que en este periódico
digamos esta noticia va en un lateral
pero va acompañada de esta imagen de los
primeros funerales de pues a dos menores
asesinados en este tiroteo masivo en la
escuela de oval de en texas triste rosa
lo que vimos ese martes pasado
precisamente y una semana gracias por
toda la revista de prensa el día de hoy
nos vemos mañana con más pasamos a
saludar a nuestra segunda mitad al día